[Music]
[Applause]
let's make this smooth segue to iron
eagle or ian igle nfl nba college
basketball broadcaster he does it all
are you sure you want to dive into this
there ryan
perfect timing completely perfect timing
for me uh annette had a very
comprehensive breakdown
except when it came to paulie how can
paulie work on himself how can he
improve
annette gave no reasons for her dislike
nothing whatsoever it's just his overall
being that's that's tough bud okay how
important is twitter to you when you do
a game
do you care what is said about you
hold on let me check how this appearance
is going
oh not very well
[Laughter]
i pay attention but i made a pact with
myself probably two years ago
not to check
during games
during games not healthy
will sway the way you might approach a
subject matter
and then depending upon the event itself
i may wait a day or two after an nfl
game to see
what the reaction might have been and
then sometimes you're pleasantly
surprised but people
were kind of into it at a 65
clip not like paulie where they had no
opinion as to why they dislike him but
i
i have
made the determination that that it
wasn't a smart move in game no
i've worked with people who checked
social media during a broadcast
not healthy no and and it it would
paralyze them because they would be so
fixated on one person saying one thing
and i finally had to shut that off if we
were doing this
show then you you couldn't be checking
social media because you were reacting
to one person and
not to a a larger audience there do you
think that kyrie irving you do the nets
games you were there for his uh his
comeback do you think kyrie cares
about
what is said about him on social media
now no
i think there was a time yes i think now
he's probably gotten to a point where
uh it's it's not something that
dominates his thoughts on a day-to-day
basis
i believe that he got to a level where
he felt he was getting nothing but hate
and negativity
and just determined that it was not
going to be productive for him or for
his group for his staff for his team
and then it becomes easily dismissible
you just dismiss
you say okay all of that we put over
here and we live our own life he
definitely beats to his own drum there's
no doubt about that
but he's pretty comfortable in doing it
and he's been highly successful doing it
so
i'm not sure that's going to change any
time soon dan i just wondered though
what kevin durant really feels about
kyrie irving because
he came there
with kyrie they bypassed the knicks
we're gonna be here together and then
all of a sudden here's durant playing
more minutes than he probably should be
playing james harden playing more
minutes than he should be playing and
meanwhile kyrie is like i don't know i
might be there might not be there
um
do you think that relationship is still
as strong as it was when he first got to
brooklyn
yeah i think it might be stronger
believe it or not and i know
it's counterintuitive because everything
you're saying
naturally would be the way that most
people would react hey what are you
doing why are you doing this to me look
at what you're doing to the team
but they've got a bond a legitimate one
and i think kd just digs
kyrie's vibe and the fact that he
doesn't
go along with what everybody wants and
to quote
a former danette
he goes against the grain
he does
and he always has and i think kevin
likes it by the way the fact that i
didn't even get a call to maybe be
a step in for mclovin was
soul crushing okay wait a minute wait a
minute you attack something you do the
nfl the nba college basketball you work
for cbs tnt tbs the nets yes westwood
westwood one yep
tennis channel
mike why don't you leave some you're
selfish you are selfish iron eagle why
don't you let somebody else do something
right i left sportscenter
so others could do it you're right you
put the eye and iron
it all comes out it hold let me lie down
because this feels more like uh all
right therapy i'll help you at this
point there's some deep stuff i need to
get to i'm glomming i need to stop the
glom
how about down time maybe spend some
time with the wife i mean why don't you
care about your family a little bit more
who's this now
uh do you think that there's a chance
kyrie gets vaccinated this year
i would say there's a chance
all of his rhetoric has not led us to
believe that that's a realistic
possibility but
i think there is a general feeling that
if you get around your teammates
you win a bunch of games you get that
feeling back like they had in indiana
the other night that championship
feeling that a part of him is going to
say all right i'm going to do it on my
terms
and i'm comfortable doing it now
because i'm doing it for the greater
good of my brothers
and i do think the nets deep down feel
like
that's still
out there but it's all on kyrie there's
still
machinations behind the scenes i'm sure
between the nets and the city and trying
to figure out moving forward if there
will be an adjustment the fact that
unvaccinated players can play at
barclays center at madison square garden
road players visiting players
and the home players cannot still
is a little bit odd uh there seems to be
a a bit of a strange loophole in that
and look the obvious thing is you put an
end to all of this
drama and conversation if you get the
shot but kyrie can play in against the
knicks in the garden right he cannot no
he cannot
well wait he's a visiting player who's
not vaccinated
right but he but he lives in the
tri-state area they put they did put an
addendum on it because initially dan i
believe there there was a feeling in
august when the word came out or at
least started to filter out that this
was going to happen that the nets
thought that kyrie was going to be okay
because his residence is new jersey and
initially it was new york city
residents and then
bill de blasio the the former mayor a
change was made to to make sure it
included tri-state area uh he is the
peripatetic iron eagle he's got the
steelers and the ravens coming up this
weekend
uh are you all set for the uh send off
for ben roethlisberger
i mean is it a send-off we have to
consider the possibility that some wacky
things happen in week 18 and the
steelers make the playoffs yes uh we we
recognize it could be the swan song but
you also have to at least keep your mind
open that
indianapolis could blow it against
jacksonville the way this season has
gone i take nothing for granted expect
the unexpected dan best team you've seen
so far this year is who
best performance i think i saw was
buffalo taking care of business josh
allen in new england and it renewed some
of those feelings that this team could
be for real depending upon what their
draw looks like in the afc the green bay
packers have been the best team in
football
and they should go in as the favorite
but everybody is beatable and this field
is wide open the separation between what
are considered the elite teams and the
second tier teams is not as wide as it's
been in the past in the nfl best team in
the nba you've seen
best team in the nba i've seen
uh look
i saw phoenix i saw golden state they're
they're both excellent they're both
tremendous chicago is the best story
cleveland probably is the second best
story
golden state and phoenix are the two
best teams right now have you run out of
ways to describe steph curry
no i i go to the thesaurus before a
steph curry assignment and and i pluck a
couple words that that might be fitting
if it works because
he is absolutely astonishing and
extraordinary in his skill level
and it's a lot of fun calling his games
kyrie irving i would say it's a similar
feeling and i did miss that i must say
as a play-by-play announcer
kyrie is at a different level in
creating highlights he's probably packed
in more highlights in his
about two seasons with the nets than i
had in my previous 26 seasons in calling
the action for brooklyn and that's
saying a lot because they've had
tremendous players kyrie is a highlight
machine as is steph curry why hasn't
brooklyn embraced the nets
no i think they have dan i've i've felt
a shift i think it was lukewarm
initially people were sampling the
product but over the last
three years
i felt something different you go into
that arena and you are seeing repeat
customers you're seeing people donning
nets paraphernalia you're seeing more of
it around the city
i think there has been a shift but you
have to win
that's the one isn't this similar to
uh the lakers to the clippers the knicks
even though the knicks haven't been
successful in a long time is that not
fair to make that
next to the knicks
clippers to the lakers comparison
i think the one difference that i'm
starting to see having grown up in the
new york area the mets were the second
team in the market the jets were the
second team in the market hockey
islanders eventually devil's second team
in the market
but they established a fan base both the
mets and the jets did it took time it
took a generation and i think the nets
are planting seeds legitimately i don't
say that just for hyperbole i really do
feel it and having done all those games
in new jersey
there was no impact and it's hard for me
to say that now but i recognize that
they were just in a black hole a chasm
of irrelevance
at the meadowlands
good luck this weekend steelers ravens
and uh it's always great to to catch up
with you and and i thank you i mean if
you would like to do a cameo and sit in
if you ever have some down time i could
see that make love because i have the
glasses yes
i have the mclovin look it's
professorial i will go with a different
take just for the sake of it yeah i'm
i'm in let's do it and paul is my
favorite but you got to be kind of
average at your job oh no no no that
that's not a problem
i'd figure it out
i'm good to talk to you thank you buddy
all right dp
uh iron eagle or ian eigel